when I think about change right I just
think about stacking days stacking days
my son is is small right he's small just
like I was and I've talked to him about
the training and how hard it is and this
that and the third but he's he's finally
starting to see a little bit of change
right in his game or whatever and his
ability and all I keep telling him is
just keep stacking days just keep
stacking days as long as you keep
stacking days I promise you I promise
you you will see the change but
my coach used to always say everything
that you want is on the other side of
hard
right he had another I think I said in
the book he said reps removed out
right reps removed out